تويتر تنسحب من اتفاقيه اوروبيه لمكافحه
المعلومات المضلله والاتحاد يقول ان
المنصه لن تستطيع التهرب من التزاماتها تم
اطلاق الميثاق الخاص بالمعلومات المضلله
في الاتحاد الاوروبي عام 2018 وانضم اليه
ما يقرب من 30 موقعا بما في ذلك متى جوجل
تويتر مايكروسوفت وتيك توك ووفق القانون
الاوسع هو قانون الخدمات الرقميه داخل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يجب على الشبكات
العملاقه مثل تويتر تقييم وتخفيف المخاطر
على الراي العام كما يجب على الشركات
زياده شفافيه فيما يتعلق بالتفاعلات مع
المستخدمين وتبسيط اتفاقيات استخدام
المنصات والمواقع ورغم انسحاب الطائر
الازرق من الاتفاقيه الا ان مفوضه السوق
الداخليه للاتحاد الاوروبي تيارتن قال انه
لن يكون بمقدوره تويتر تمصل من مسؤولياتها
في هذا الاطار المسؤول الاوروبي اعلن 25
من اغسطس المقبل سيكون موعدا لتنفيذ
البنود والالتزامات التي يتضمنها القانون
وان على جميع الشبكات والمنصات مقدمه
الخدمات الرقميه في المنطقه الاوروبيه
الالتزام بها بمقتضى القانون لكن ما
الخيارات المتاحه حقيقه امام الاتحاد
الاوروبي اي انتهاك لقانون الخدمات
الرقميه الاوروبي سيعرض الشركه المخالفه
لعقوبات باهظه تصل قيمتها الى دفع 6% من
حجم العوائد السنويه لها كما ان تكرار
المخالفه قد يؤدي الى حجب المنصه داخل دول
الاتحاد وفي حاله تويتر سيعني ذلك خساره
المنصه لما يقرب من
440 مليون مستخدم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات